hey guys it's just aid and today in
front of me we have one of the first one
plus seven pros to check out I'm so
excited this was just announced and now
we're gonna do an unboxing and I take
this thing out and do some testing so in
front of us we have the new one plus
seven pro and we have the new bullets
Wireless - and this this is a one plus
warp charge thirty car charger now let's
unbox the one plus seven pro this is the
nebula blue version that would be
slowest reveal ever here it is oh it
feels a little heavier than I thought
like I said this is the nebula blue
version oh wow there's one thing that
one class does right is the color it's
like this is so beautiful but you take a
look at that I think I need to change my
background color now to nebula blue hold
on a second
that looks pretty nebulae to me I think
that works what is this this is this
we're a pop-up camera could potentially
be I think so this is the one +7 pro in
the nebula blue it features a Qualcomm
Snapdragon 805 processor and up to 12
gigs of RAM this model has 256 gigs of
storage and the display is a six point
six seven inch qHD fluid AMOLED and yes
it does have a pop-up front-facing 16
megapixel camera there's a triple lens
setup on the back there's an ultra wide
angle which is 117 degrees a 16
megapixel sensor there's a telephoto
lens which is 3x optical and the main
lens which is a forty eight megapixel
sensor it also features work charge 30
and a four thousand milliamp battery
there's dual speakers with Dolby Atmos
night mode 2.0 haptic vibration and a 10
layer liquid cooling system it also
comes in three colors this is the nebula
blue there's also a near black and an
almond so that's a little overview of
the oneplus 7 pro I'm gonna set this
thing up and then we're gonna take this
thing outside but first I also have a
few other things inside this box that we
need to check out here of course we've
got a nice clear case which I'm going to
put on immediately
oh my goodness this is aggressive and of
course my favorite the red USB C
charging cables anything else in here
like something I can eat no but we do
have a SIM card ejector which I am gonna
need it let's take a look at this car
charger hmm very nice another one just
what I need
and we've also got the oneplus bullet
wireless to headphones
[Applause]
oh well that was easier than I thought I
love this case I loved it in the last
version and I'm still loving it we've
got various sizes depending upon your
ear size yeah look at you I'll always
love the bullets design especially these
little magnetic ear pieces these also
have work charge so if you charge them
for ten minutes that will give you ten
hours of playback it's also got quick
pair so you can pair two different
devices and you can easily switch
between the two devices by pressing
twice on the shortcut key on the
headphones so let's get this thing set
up and I'll meet you guys outside so
it's all set up but before I go outside
I need to add some security on here I
don't have my fingerprint set up so
right now I'm gonna do that much like
the previous version the fingerprint
sensor is inside of the screen yeah I'm
getting some haptic feedback you guys
can't see it continue to adjust the
position of your finger all right I'm
scanning every part of my finger
there it is some finger print added
let's try it
ready
that was super quick now
there's something that I want to show
you guys this is something that I
haven't tried yet I've been holding off
for this very moment
okay are you ready feast your little
eyes right here watch this watch
hi Tyler
it's so incredible so in this reviewers
guide this is something that I want to
read you guys because this is really
fascinating the pop up cameras elevator
mechanism has been tested over three
hundred thousand times so this means
that if you were to use the camera 150
times a day you can still be able to use
it over five years but as many selfies
as I take I'm gonna flip this around and
there's a picture of Tyler here is the
wide angle here is the regular here is
the 3x optical my gosh I'm so soon did
on you oh what'd you do some portrait
feel sooo portrait oh wow oh my gosh
this is going in GQ okay let's see can
we do front-facing portrait yes yes sir
definitely going in vogue there's also
nightscape to knock them tests out yet
because it's not nighttime let's do a
quick little video test shooting in 4k
Wow whoa the zoom in is fierce
hey would you push the push the 1x
button
so it only shoots 1080p on the front
camera but that's pretty much like most
cameras this is riveting content I think
it is don't worry we're gonna take this
thing outside we're gonna test it out a
little more but this is the front-facing
camera hello hello hello
I just like to do a preliminary test
before I head outside into the wild cuz
you never know what you're gonna get
anytime I get a new phone to review my
favorite thing to test out is the camera
so I'm gonna take some photos and some
videos for you guys and I would love to
know what you guys think so the first
picture I'm gonna take is using the
ultra wide paratus ears regular and here
is the 3x zoomed in yeah
I'm gonna flip this around
it's really it's really great like
probably my best that's work ever now
I'm testing out the front-facing video
one of the things that I have noticed
even just looking back at the footage
that I shot yesterday using this camera
oneplus really doesn't do a good job
with audio so the microphone sounds a
little bit tinny so here's a comparison
to what the iphone sounds like okay
we're shooting side by side this is the
iPhone and this is the oneplus 7th row
so you guys can tell that the audio on
the iPhone definitely sounds a lot
better so that is one thing that I
really wish that oneplus would kind of
step up their game Davone so far is
pretty awesome
it is pretty speedy looking at them side
by side not sure what do you guys think
I'm leaving this up to you oh my gosh
I'm a photographer
Master Geographic tweet me if you want
that shot because it's really my best
work so the camera is using ultra shot
which is hdr+ so it's controlling the
exposure value of each pixel and it
collects four times more data so a super
resolution it extracts key information
from each photo and then it takes all of
those photos layers them together and
then you get more detail in each shot
that you take I'm loving it I'm gonna go
take a few more photos and I will do a
little montage here for you guys some
pictures that I took
[Music]
when the pop-up camera pops up there's a
really cool animation that happens I got
to show you guys this so it happens
right up here
are you ready look at it I'm almost at
my daily 150 limit Maddie are you a good
boy hey who's the best boy is it you is
it you let me do a little wide angle of
you let's do a portrait hug
Maddie Maddie do you think this will be
your new profile pic these portrait mode
photos actually look really good
okay you MIDI this is something that I
have been waiting this entire video to
test out I wanted to do a drop test
because it says that the camera would
retract when it texts free fall so using
the accelerometer and the gyroscope
inside the phone it knows when you drop
it so I thought I would use this lovely
flush loveSac here put the camera into
slow-mo and drop it and see if we can
catch this retracting Tyler are you
ready
[Music]
oh my gosh this is incredible so it
definitely detected the fall because you
could see in the slow-mo shop we need to
replay this look at that the camera just
retracted as a detective the fall and on
here it gives you a notification that it
says free fall detected the front camera
has been lowered would you like to use
the front camera again yes this is great
Wow there's a night mode 2.0 so when you
click this this will filter out all of
the shortwave blu-rays that affect your
vision so if you're watching content in
the dark or before bed this is whole
much easier on your eyes oh it sounds so
good too
[Music]
whoa this is testing out the dolby atmos
speakers this is the first time that I'm
actually watching this and you can
really hear this around town
I don't think Dolby Atmos man it's
finally dark enough the test output one
plus seven pro in some load light
situations I'm using the night shot
feature and train going by so here's
shot
[Music]
[Applause]
this also has a gaming mode and I was
downloading fortnight but I was taking
too long so I have another really
incredible game that I was just
searching on the Google Play Store and I
saw this
it's a Chuckie Cheese skateboarding game
I know
oxygen OS now has a screen recorder
built-in so I can go in here and I can
screen record this incredible gameplay
but you guys are about to witness
another cool thing about the screen
recording is when you go in here to into
the settings you can go into the audio
source so you can choose to not record
the audio just record the internal audio
of the game or you can activate your
microphone so you can record not only
the gameplay audio but your own voice so
I'm gonna do that I'm sorry my gaming
chimney back up again maybe I jump over
it yep okay okay okay I got it now now
that I figured it out I am unstoppable
[Music]
I'm going pro you'll see me in the next
eSports world League of chuck-e-cheese
skateboarding fish whoa did you see that
trick so I think we get the point I'm
gonna stop my recording now so let's say
I've been playing chuck-e-cheese skate
unlimited for four hours I'm exhausted I
ran into so many blocks and snowmen I
need to take a break well there is a
really cool Zen mode on here now which
is awesome because this will pretty much
disable your phone for 20 minutes you
can still make and receive emergency
calls but for the most part
notifications and everything else
disabled so I think that's probably a
good point thing we can end this video
now thank you guys so much for watching
I'm going to hit Zen mode now I'm gonna
Zen out
enjoy the company of your pets enjoy
romantic whoa look at that you're some
rolls Zen mode can't be canceled once it
started Oh incoming notifications will
be temporarily muted you may still
receive calls and make emergency calls
all apps will be locked except for the
camera let's hit start three two one go
so here's the emergency call okay what
about no needs phone number here's the
camera so useful access to that so
that's good okay so you take an
emergency selfie so that's really cool I
now have 19 minutes and 27 seconds until
I can use my phone again thank you guys
so much for watching hope you guys
enjoyed this video I'm really excited to
test this out a little bit more let me
know if there's any other videos you'd
like me to make with the new one plus 7
huge thank you to oneplus for sending me
this phone to check out I always love
reviewing their phones let me know if
there's anything else you guys would
like to see me test with the oneplus 7
pro I had so much fun making this video
I hope you guys enjoyed it don't forget
to subscribe and also hit the bell if
you haven't already that's how you'll be
notified when I post new videos now I'm
gonna go is N Out and not really sure
what I'm gonna do for 18 minutes like
I'll probably just go pick up my iphone
it's your real that I have a backup
phone for your zentral phone
[Music]